Jumba 23rd go down in our history as our
independence girl well it happened the
United Kingdom voted to leave the
European Union a move that has left part
of the country celebrating and part of
it well and disbelief but as fears begin
to set in about the UK's future we gotta
ask who won after breakfast let's start
with who didn't really win the UK on the
political front for starters is
currently in total chaos Prime Minister
David Cameron immediately announced his
resignation after the results came out
the British people have made a very
clear decision to take a different path
and as such I think the country requires
fresh leadership to take it in this
direction that's the same David Cameron
who in 2013 promised a referendum vote
in order to appease members of his own
Conservative Party so David Cameron not
only then there's a leader of the
Opposition jeremy corbyn members of
Corbin's Labour Party voted 172 240
against him in a no-confidence motion
accusing him of not doing enough to
convince voters to remain in the EU but
Corbin has said he will not step down so
Corbin and labour also not winners is it
time to resign is it time to resign are
you going to resign what about the next
prime minister cameron says that he
won't be the one to begin the process of
withdrawal from the EU by invoking
article 50 of the Lisbon Treaty he'll be
leaving backer glitch to his successor
so clearly the next prime minister won't
be a winner because we'll have to deal
with the financial and economic fallout
of leaving the EU then there's Scotland
which voted overwhelmingly to remain
with
you Scottish politicians now say they
want their own referendum on
independence from the UK so the next
prime minister will have the task of
trying to keep the Union together but
who is up for losing the most well the
people pensions are in trouble the pound
plummeted to a 31-year low and over 2
trillion dollars were wiped off from the
global market and immigrant workers
especially are in trouble much of the
leave campaigns rhetoric focused on
stoking fear of immigrants reports say
dozens of racist incidents have occurred
in the days since the referendum but it
goes beyond that being an EU citizen
means that you have the right to live
work and reside in any EU Member country
but for nearly three million EU migrants
currently in the UK they may have
technically lost their right to do so
now there have to be some winners right
well this guy Nigel Farage has been all
smiles as well as a lot of Brits who
seem to think voting leave means that
all immigrants need to get out oh jeez
would it were you 18 19 Togo so sure
many Brits think they've taken back
their country but how good is that when
the country is barely holding on